[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP l'émission on
parle cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie et un peu politique et cette
semaine nous recevons Jean-Noël Barrault
bonjour et bienvenue merci d'être avec
nous et avec moi pour présenter cette
émission Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour
Jean-Pierre bonjour Brigitte
délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications vous
êtes également secrétaire général du
MoDem député des Yvelines depuis 2017
après des études au prestigieux lycées
Henri IV vous faites HEC Sciences Po
docteur en sciences de gestion vous
devenez professeurs au célèbre mit
économiste de profession vous intégrez
logiquement la Vice-Présidente de la
commission des finances à l'Assemblée
parlementaire comme votre grand-père et
votre père avant vous pas de népotisme
non chez les barreaux vous l'avez vu on
sait se faire un prénom voler de ses
propres ailes mais on retourne toujours
au nid familial la Haute-Loire qui a
inspirer le menu du jour exactement au
menu Brigitte un plat paysan et ce n'est
pas péjoratif dans ma bouche un chou
farci et on desserre un éclair au café
dans le dessous des plats que nous
réserve à l'avenir notre assiette et
bien visitons le ciel le Salon
International de l'Alimentation ou se
dessine les grandes tendances et les
innovations culinaires de demain dans
les pieds dans le plat la sacro-sainte
baguette française est-elle menacée oui
les boulangers sont dans le pétrin après
la flambée des prix de l'énergie allez
on passe à table tout de suite cuisine
et confidence
monsieur le ministre ma mission étant de
comprendre ce que dit de vous le plat
que vous avez choisi j'ai d'abord été
perplexe avant de consulter un
psychanalyste de comptoir je vous
rassure qui m'a dit c'est simple avec
son chou farci Jean-Noël barreau démine
le terrain ah bon oui il vous adresse
des messages subliminaux d'abord ne pas
lui prendre le chou avec l'affaire des
pirates informatiques qui s'attaquent à
nos hôpitaux ça pourrait lui couper
l'appétit ensuite ne pas lui farcir la
tête avec mes histoires de boxe que je
dois réinitialiser pour voir les matchs
n'oublie pas qu'il est ministre du
numérique pas technicien mais je me
demande quand même si mon psy en carton
n'est pas dans les choux 40 ans ancien
élu dit Saint Jo en Haute-Loire terre de
ce plat paysan qui est le chou farci le
seul message en fait que vous voulez
nous faire passer c'est que le chou
farci trop souvent méprisé reste un
monument de notre gastronomie est-ce que
je me trompe vous avez raison un
monument d'ailleurs
il est vrai que les Auvergnats le
revendiquent je crois qu'il y a aussi
d'autres régions de France qui le
revendiquent et donc quand vous m'avez
proposé de participer à cette émission
ce que j'ai accepté avec grand plaisir
je me suis demandé ce qu'elle est valoir
votre chou farcies
on va le goûter avec tout de suite et
puis vous allez nous dire s'il
correspond à peu près à
l'habitude de manger il y a la tradition
auvergnate mais c'est aussi une
tradition un peu familiale puisque
chaque année le 24 au soir c'est ma
maman qui préparait le le chou farci et
qui nous qui nous faisait participer moi
et mes sœurs à sa préparation qui
consistait d'abord à sélectionner le
chou puis à
enfin nettoyer le nettoyer quoi le faire
un peu bouillir dans l'eau pour pour
éliminer la terre etc puis ça le
décortiquer à faire la farce en
parallèle et puis ensuite à reconstruire
le chou avec la carte
de millefeuille
une habitude une tradition de Noël que
j'ai reprises à mon compte puisque le
refait tous les 24 décembre alors on le
refait bien sûr dans le cadre familial
mais je le fais aussi désormais avec mes
amis et il est désormais
sur le choix tout le monde mais je les
invite en tout cas le à le déguster mon
épouse Marina évidemment me donne un
coup de main pour la préparation et donc
on a cette espèce de repas préparatoire
à Noël on invite les amis pour pour
déguster le chou farci et pour passer un
bon moment à la fin de l'année et c'est
ce qu'on s'apprête à faire d'ailleurs
dans les prochains jours puisque noël
approche est-ce qu'il est meilleur que
celui de votre attendre
dites nous quand même parce que il est
certainement moins bon que celui de
votre maman évidemment mais j'espère que
ce chou farci de chez François se se
distingue quand même et moi Brigitte si
vous voulez pas mal
il est pas mal il est pas mal le verdict
est tombé trois choses à savoir du coup
pour réussiront
sa maman doit être très au point alors
très vite d'abord pour la farce pour la
réussite il faut mettre du bœuf du veau
et du porc parce que ça apporte un peu
de moelleux donc je conseille soit du
gras qui fait du moineau exactement un
peu de temps de Cheetah et puis ou de la
chair à saucisse et si vous voulez faire
un chou farci un peu de Noël puisque
c'est le 24 décembre mettez une petite
touche de foie gras ça le dope c'est pas
mal pour le chou choisir un gros chou
vert les feuillets le faire cuire dans
l'eau bouillante salée avec une pointe
de bicarbonate et ensuite vous mettez
votre chou dans l'eau glacée ça va lui
conserver cette couleur verte et il sera
plus joli sur table parce que ça va
fixer la chlorophylle enfin comment
farcir le chou bah ça c'est une vraie
question il y a la méthode cool on
tapisse un moule de feuilles de chou et
puis on dépose la farce avant de
refermer avec une ficelle et on englobe
tout ou alors on met une feuille de chou
de la farce une feuille de chou un peu
comme des lasagnes mais c'est un peu
plus compliqué je ne sais pas quelle
méthode vous utilisez un mix des deux
de construire le chou la boule mais en
intercalant de la face entre entre les
feuilles et puis la le secret
c'est de rajouter du lard autour du chou
une fois que le choix est constitué
avant la cuisson alors là aussi donner
un peu de
tout donc c'est des petits choux
individuels où vous faites un grand chou
nous on est plutôt grand-chose
une belle boule verte
effectivement on le tranche et si c'est
bien compact ça reste ça se ça se voilà
ça se maintient bien et alors vous
mettez une petite sauce avec la fée chez
Françoise
pas vraiment on peut le manger
évidemment en accompagnement du chapon
ou de la dinde de Noël qui elle-même
vient avec sa sauce voilà mais la sauce
pour le coup qui a été retenue par le
vous êtes viandes
avec un chapeau
il y a la farce dans le chou c'est Noël
c'est assez riche c'est assez riche mais
c'est Noël donc vous vous mangez
beaucoup de viande c'est ça c'est ce
qu'il faut comprendre le reste de
l'année pas tellement mais évidemment
pour les fêtes de fin d'année on fait
quelques exceptions cette recette c'est
un plat paysan nous a dit nous a dit
Jean-Pierre c'est une recette que qu'on
mange parce que vous c'est une tradition
c'est le 24 décembre mais là-bas en
Haute-Loire on en trouve presque tous
les jours c'est un plat du quotidien ou
pas
non je gérais pas jusqu'à dire ça mais
je pense que c'est une une tradition qui
nous rappelle d'abord à la diversité des
cuisines dans notre pays de la richesse
de notre gastronomie qui s'appuie sur
des produits très simples comme le chou
que parfois regardé avec un petit peu de
dédain alors même qui peut régaler nos
papis au moment de Noël
oui c'est ce que j'allais dire ça
réhabilite le chou le chou a souvent été
méprisé parce que d'abord il peut
dégager une petite odeur quand on le
cuit et puis c'est vrai
donc on le fait non mais c'est connu
pour ça aussi on le fait blanchir donc
pour justement bouillir un peu pour
qu'il soit effectivement plus et le
bicarbonate de soude peut aussi aider à
le digérer c'est pas c'est vachement
utile le bicarbonate de soude mais c'est
vrai que ça a été un peu délaissé mais
ça revient il y a plein de bons restos
même à Paris en province maintenant qui
revisite ce chou farcies
il y a une autre spécialité auvergnate
avec laquelle j'ai beaucoup hésité la
beauté alors non pas la potée le ce
qu'on appelle le petit salé aux
lentilles ou que nous appelons nous à
Yssingeaux la jambonnette aux lentilles
et qui restait là pour le coup un plat
assez courant même si voilà on en mange
pas tous les jours mais qui est assez
courant alors au plus anglais on a la
chance d'avoir
et puis et puis évidemment le le
la tradition de de charcuterie qui est
assez qui est assez forte charcuterie
Auvergnate et donc voilà c'est deux
plages j'irai pas qu'on en mange
toujours mais ils sont ils sont là
et le ministre fourneau ça donne quoi
par le chou farci quels sont vos autres
aux autres trouvailles est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas monomaniaque quand même vous
ne faites pas que le chou farci quand
vous mettez à faire de la cuisine alors
malheureusement les obligations les
servitudes associées à la charge je me
laisse pas beaucoup
on peut toujours il faut toujours
trouver du temps pour cuisiner
malheureusement je retrouve pas assez
d'eau qui m'arrive de il m'arrive de
d'observer à la maison le week-end les
les recettes les recettes coconstruites
si on peut dire par les par mes enfants
et leurs mamans
et quand à Bercy on a la chance d'être
évidemment
très bien traité très bien servi et
d'être et de pouvoir aussi très bien
accueillir nos interlocuteurs donc je ne
me plains pas vous avez importé le chou
farci à Bercy ou pas est-ce qu'on s'en
sert à la table
c'est une très bonne idée je suis sûr
qu'il arrangerait d'une manière comme
ils savent faire avec beaucoup de choses
avec beaucoup de talents d'une manière
très réussie
sinon au ministère sur des plats que
vous souhaiteriez manger parce que vous
vous mangez de tout ou vous avez des
préférences
je mange de tout je mange de tout
évidemment je j'ai au fil des années
limité un petit peu ma consommation de
viande pas pour des raisons idéologiques
pour des raisons de forme physique on va
dire bon voilà et donc c'est la seule
indication que que j'ai donné
et donc à certains repas je vais prendre
un repas plutôt végétal végétarien comme
dans certains ministères
ça peut être un peu plus ça peut être un
peu moins en gros quand je quand je
prends un repas dans mon bureau et que
je travaille pendant l'heure du repas je
vais je vais prendre un repas végétarien
et comme quand je suis avec des autres
je m'adapte en quelque sorte au menu des
autres et en tant que ministre de la
transition économique vous n'êtes pas
toujours sur votre applis pour vous
faire un livret des plats non c'est pas
votre comme nous tous les les
applications sont entrées dans dans nos
vies pour le meilleur d'ailleurs un peu
pour le pire parfois mais pour le
meilleur d'abord pour le
pour la pour l'accès à la santé pour
l'accès
à des livraisons de repas et donc à
certains services auxquels on n'avait
pas forcément accès auparavant ou pour
lequel il fallait se livrer
régulièrement ça peut vous arriver ça
m'arrive oui notamment à Versailles où
je réside il nous arrive de faire de
faire livrer un repas ouais alors on va
voir si vous êtes vraiment incollable
c'est le quiz
alors la ville d'Yssingeaux qui vous est
très cher et connu pour sa brioche la
brioche la brioche yssinjeau vous
connaissez Brigitte
ces affirmations la concernant est
fausse elle a été mise au point ça c'est
la première affirmation a par un
boulanger du cru Hippolyte machaber vrai
ou faux il existe même une confrérie de
la brioche d'Yssingeaux vrai ou faux
vrai
son secret c'est son parfum de cannelle
et de muscade
fleur d'oranger
parfait vrai faux et elle est apparu en
ouais exactement
la recette sur comme le lait sur le feu
d'accord que cette recette ancestrale
soit bien respectée ceci explique cela
puisque comme vous le savez je n'avais
je ne le suis plus élu ni habitant
d'Yssingeaux
à la confrérie mon souhait dans d'en
être d'en faire partie alors un nouveau
quiz on sait que vous êtes fan de chou
pourriez-vous nous dire quel type de
chou parmi ces quatre n'existe pas à le
chou vivace
B le chou à grosse cote
comme les velours
le Choupo mais c'est aider le chou blanc
le chou blanc
donc c'est quasiment tout bon pour ce
quiz alors que c'est quand même assez
difficile et vous vous aimez faire le
marché sinon acheter des bons produits
le dimanche matin
très jolie marché à Versailles très joli
marché
plus beau marché d'Île-de-France pour le
marché Notre-Dame mais il y a aussi un
marché très sympathique dans mon
quartier de porschefontaine
ça m'arrive mais je je
mets mon épouse et extrêmement exigeante
quand je vais au marché
je suis un petit peu
stressé de ramener à la maison des
produits qui ne sont pas de
d'excellentes qualités vous avez la
liste comme ça réaliste mais je même
avec la liste il faut il faut il faut
faire les bons choix qu'elle vous donne
les bonnes adresses là où il faut aussi
même quand vous êtes devant un étal il
faut il faut encore savoir choisir le
bon légume le bon fruit au toucher à
l'odorat qu'il faut faire confiance
souvent quand on connaît bien les
promarcheurs voilà au marché parce que
ils sont de bon conseil général
carton jaune parfois au retour voir le
carton rouge
[Rires]
petite biscotte comme ça
sinon vous achetez bio ou vous achetez
local vous faites attention à ça votre
femme elle vous demande du bio par
exemple non je crois qu'on fait
attention à ça en particulier depuis que
on a de jeunes enfants et qu'on est très
attentif à la manière dont il se
nourrissent dont il s'alimente
et on privilégie les produits de qualité
on évite au maximum les les plats
transformés pour pour éviter
effectivement tous ces les selles et
tous les selles qui sont contenues
exactement donc oui en étant en fait
mais très attentif à tout ça alors vous
savez qu'en France le repas occupe une
large place et particulièrement en
politique c'est souvent là que ce nous
les deals politiques se fait la petite
et la grande Histoire et c'est la brève
de comptoir
[Musique]
sans pour autant mettre engagé auprès de
lui pendant ses campagnes
présidentielles et puis je voyais
émerger Emmanuel Macron et autour de lui
un certain nombre de personnes qui parmi
lesquels je comptais des amis
c'était l'époque de la primaire des
républicains Alain Juppé était favoris
et d'ailleurs je soutenais la
candidature d'Alain Juppé et puis je
fais un petit message au mois de juillet
à François Bayrou qui me dit vient des
genoux ensemble le 16 août et donc au
milieu des vacances je me suis rendu à
Paris parce qu'il faut savoir que le au
mois d'août François baillon le travail
il écrit notamment pour le retrouver et
c'est à ce moment là qu'on a que nous
avons que nous avons parlé et que et qui
m'a et qui m'a invité à le rejoindre
plus activement à rejoindre le bureau
exécutif du MoDem en faisant un
diagnostic très clair et très lucide de
la situation du politique du pays qui
s'est révélé très juste à savoir que
malgré ce que l'on pouvait lire dans les
sondages il n'était pas garantis que à
la puisse emporter la primaire tant les
primaires font ressortir les candidats
les plus radicaux dans leur sein au sein
des parties c'est la théorie de les les
parties se tiennent par leur noyau et
que dès lors que la primaire de la
droite ne ferait pas émerger à l'injupé
mais un candidat plus radical comme
François Fillon et que la primaire de la
gauche ferait émerger un candidat
radical comme Benoît Hamon alors il y
aurait un boulevard au centre à l'époque
ça aurait pu être un boulevard pris par
François bayrouet le modem l'histoire en
a décidé autrement mais c'est ce
déjeuner là que nous avons eu ce 16 août
et cet échange qui est qui a déterminé
en quelque sorte une bonne partie de ce
qui m'est arrivé ensuite en politique à
partir de l'été 2017 c'est-à-dire un an
plus tard pour 5 ans à l'Assemblée et
désormais quelques mois au gouvernement
mais à l'époque François Bayrou faisait
cavalier seul à l'époque il soutenait
encore Emmanuel Macron à l'époque il
soutenait à la Juppé comme comme moi
et qu'est-ce que vous aviez mangé ce
jour-là
c'était l'été et donc je pense que si ma
mémoire est bonne pour ma part ça devait
être du du poisson cru
et quelque chose de frais en tout cas
c'est ce que j'ai gardé c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on a des repas qui sont
peut-être peut-être un peu plus frugaux
qu'avant et est-ce que du temps de votre
grand-père de votre père vous avez vu
une évolution dans la façon dont les
repas politiques se tiennent parce que
avant souviens de Jacques Chirac avec
des repas très fournis même ils mangent
plusieurs fois par jour plusieurs
déjeuners plusieurs dîners vous avez vu
cette évolution là vous vous avez
remarqué ça
oui il y a de toute évidence une
évolution des comportements mais qui
suit en réalité l'évolution de de la
société quand j'étais jeune dans les
années 80 à Yssingeaux ont mangé tous
les jours de la de la viande ou du
poisson presque à tous les repas c'est
quelque chose qu'on qui a quand même
beaucoup évolué et même si même si ça
peut arriver dans certaines familles
dans certains foyers on voit bien que
dans d'autres c'est une habitude qui
s'est complètement perdue et je pense
que ces habitudes là en fait les
responsables politiques les les prennent
en même temps si je puis dire que les
que les concitoyens et donc
et donc de la même manière on voit à la
fois dans la dans les dans les cuisines
des ministères mais aussi dans les
habitudes individuelles des des membres
du gouvernement ou des députés un peu
plus de place au
plat végétariens un peu moins de place
au vert de 20 midi un peu moins de place
aussi
fromage c'est fromage de dessert mais
comme disait
il mangeait peut-être un chou farci le
matin le soir et à midi là aujourd'hui
on regarde un petit peu c'est les
boissons light qui ont été qui sont
apparus à l'Assemblée voilà on fait
attention et puis et puis et puis une
fois que les habitudes sont prises vous
vous connaissez bien mieux que moi mais
une fois que vous avez l'habitude de
d'un régime particulier lorsque vous
engendez vous vous sentez immédiatement
une gêne etc et dans des journées qui
peuvent être particulièrement intenses
quand on est au Parlement quand on est
au gouvernement une fatigue aussi qu'on
va vouloir éviter en restant sur un
régime dans lequel on est
progressivement entré donc pas de
révolution je dirais mais une évolution
progressive des usages dans le pays qui
se traduit effectivement dans les
pratiques politiques alors il y a les
plats traditionnels comme le chou farci
et puis il y a les innovations
culinaires celles qu'on retrouvera
demain dans notre assiette c'est le
dessous des plats
vous voulez savoir Brigitte ce que nous
aurons à l'avenir dans nos assiettes et
bien les aliments du futur les
innovations les nouveaux concepts
alimentaires sont exposés au ciel le
Salon International de l'Alimentation
qui s'est tenu à Paris en octobre
dernier et la visite guidée est tenue
par Emilie spertinot
ah c'est gourmand ça
a l'air tout simple mais c'est l'une des
innovations culinaires les plus
prometteuses du moment des algues
surgelés sous forme de défrisoler dans
la poêle
ce qu'on recherche là vraiment c'est
cette croustillance qu'on l'a qu'on va
laisser pousser à la cuisson et une fois
que c'est bien croustillant ça vient
servir vraiment comme un légume un
second accompagnement dans vos assiettes
avec du riz des pâtes une poêlée de
légumes une salade c'est un menteur
Tanguy et Vincent sont breton et
passionnés de cuisine alors ils ont
cette idée exploiter un ingrédient
naturel présent en grande quantité dans
leur environnement qui poussent tout
seul sans eau douce et sans engrais
c'est vraiment des potagers marins qui
sont cultivés par des agglocuteurs et
avec eux voilà on essaye d'innover de
trouver des nouvelles façons de
consommer l'algue et mettre l'algue
française au cœur de l'assiette on a des
dérèglements climatiques qui font que
les les sols sont moins productifs donc
comment se nourrir plus durablement et
on pense que face à ça l'acte de culture
est une réponse crédible à ces enjeux ce
salon c'est donc la vitrine de
nombreuses start-up mais aussi un
avant-goût très concret de nos futurs
assiettes bien sûr il y a beaucoup de
choses qui ont émergé ici ou on se
posait des questions au départ par
exemple les premiers produits à base de
soja que ce soit des des substitudes
produits laitiers ou de viande par
exemple on les a vu arriver sur le salon
proposé aux professionnels c'était des
tout petits marchés au départ et puis
c'est devenu ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui ce que l'on voit ici on le
verra dans les cuisines des
consommateurs demain et peut-être même
après demain dans vos assiettes d'ici
quelques mois peut-être glisserez vous
cette petite truite bio en conserve
pêché dans les Pyrénées un produit qui
n'existait tout simplement pas
une alternative à la surpêche des
sardines je me suis aperçu qu'il y avait
aucune conserve labellisée bio puisque
le poisson de mer la sardine l'anchois
le maquereau le thon ne peuvent pas être
labellisés et on a décidé de mettre en
boîte du coup des petits truites et
qu'on transforme exactement comme des
sardines des saveurs nouvelles plus
proches de la nature locale mais aussi
zéro déchet la grande tendance du moment
chez les startups françaises comme cette
eau pétillante à faire soi-même à l'aide
d'une poudre ce qu'on veut être ce qu'on
veut faire c'est proposer une
alternative aux boissons en bouteilles
également une alternative aux machines
de gaz à effet
le principe on verse dans un litre d'eau
du robinet deux sachets contenant des
bicarbonate de potassium
donc là c'est la production de CO2 donc
c'est normal il y a une certaine
effervescence
donc on retourne deux trois fois la
bouteille
on a que les poutres soient parfaitement
dissoute ça prend moins d'une minute et
quand l'eau redevient limpide
et on peut déguster on a on a un litre
et vous pouvez d'ores et déjà retrouver
l'eau pétillante en poudre elle vient
tout juste d'être commercialisé dans un
millier de grandes surfaces
alors Monsieur ministre ça vous fait
saliver est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
troquer votre chou farci contre une de
ces innovations là ces petites algues ça
vous fait kiffer je sais pas si ça me
fait kiffer mais en tout cas je salue
l'esprit de créativité des entrepreneurs
français de ce qu'on appelle
la grottech et je dois dire d'ailleurs
qu'on la soutient puisque avec mon
ministère et le ministère de
l'Agriculture nous avons lancé un
programme
agrivain qui qui va accompagner pendant
toute l'année 22 entrepreneurs qui ont
été sélectionnés de la grille tech ou de
la grottech dans leur projet de
développement en les mettant en relation
avec des financiers des clients
potentiels et plus généralement en les
aidant à surmonter tous les obstacles
qui se dressent sur leur route donc oui
c'est une très bonne chose que d'avoir
toutes ces innovations certaines
on les retrouvera dans quelques années
dans nos assiettes certaines non mais
c'est pas grave c'est ça l'innovation
pépite là que vous soutenez est-ce qu'il
y a des innovations en matière de foot
tech vraiment est-ce qu'il y a là on a
vu des algues congelés est-ce que vous
vous voilà est-ce que l'État soutient
par exemple ou quelque chose qu'on ne
connaîtrait pas encore ou est-ce que
c'est des insectes par exemple est-ce
que alors vous parlez des insectes c'est
c'est un point très intéressant le
président du jury pour ce programme
agrivant pour sélectionner les
entrepreneurs c'est le fondateur de
insec c'est très belle entreprise
française qui est en train de de
révolutionner l'alimentation animale et
les engrais en basculant les en
basculant sur les insectes et les larves
d'insectes qui permettent de réduire
énormément l'empreinte carbone de ce
secteur donc pour pouvoir contrôler les
spectateurs comprennent bien c'est à
dire que nos volailles nos cochons vont
maintenant manger les insectes ça a été
autorisé et c'est le processus est parti
c'est ça
c'est surtout pour les animaux parce que
c'est en partie tout à fait c'est pour
les il y a maintenant des des
producteurs d'insectes pour
l'alimentation humaine mais ils sont ils
sont encore à l'état un peu embryonnaire
même s'il y a une de quelques
entreprises françaises qui sont sur ce
créneau pour l'alimentation animale et
les engrais les insectes et les larves
d'insectes vont permettre de réduire
drastiquement la les émissions carbone
de du secteur et donc de la viande que
nous dégustons dans nos assiettes donc
vous voyez comment par l'innovation on
peut aussi faire baisser l'empreinte
carbone plutôt que de rejeter un peu de
manière idéologique et aveugle la
consommation de viande réfléchir à la
manière dont on peut réduire l'empreinte
carbone de l'élevage et c'est ce à quoi
s'en plaint cette magnifique start-up
française qui s'appelle insecte et qui
est basé dans le Jura et à Amiens pour
ses usines de production on voit que
donc l'innovation est au secours de la
transition énergétique est-ce que
l'innovation elle va permettre aussi de
nourrir là on a 8 milliards d'humains
donc peut-être 10 milliards demain plus
tard est-ce que c'est possible justement
d'avoir plus de nourriture grâce à
l'innovation en food tech je crois
absolument et il y a des des substituts
qui émergent on a vu à l'image dans le
reportage des des produits à base
d'algues on parlait des produits à base
d'insectes il y a bon comme on
l'évoquait tout à l'heure les les
habitudes alimentaires ont la vie dure
c'est c'est compliqué de changer le
contenu de de son assiette mais
progressivement ça ça évolue et puis le
dérèglement climatique va mettre
nos agricultures dans le monde à rue des
preuves et il y aura sans doute comme on
l'a on l'a vu déjà avec la guerre en
Ukraine des moments de tension forte sur
certaines matières premières agricoles
sur certains aliments auxquels il faudra
bien qu'on trouve des substituts ça veut
dire que l'innovation elle est aussi au
secours de la souveraineté alimentaire
elle est au secours de la souveraineté
alimentaire mais de l'alimentation de la
planète dans ensemble je pense qu'il
sera qui sera mise à rude épreuve dans
notre pays qui est un grand pays
agricole certes mais aussi dans d'autres
pays qui dépendent très largement de
grandes puissances agricoles comme la
nôtre pour pour se nourrir et donc pour
survivre vous savez quand nous quand je
reçois des homologues qui nous qui
viennent nous visiter depuis par exemple
Moyen-Orient et que l'on parle numérique
et que l'on parle l'innovation et qu'on
parle start-up la première chose qu'il
nous demande c'est
quelles sont les startups agricoles et
quels sont les services qu'elle pourrait
nous apporter à nous puisque ce sont des
pays qui qui ont vécu les tensions sur
le prix et la disponibilité de blé par
exemple avec beaucoup beaucoup
d'inquiétudes parce que voilà les les
pénuries c'est quelque chose de très
concret quand ça quand ça touche à
l'assiette quand ça vient nous concerner
dans notre vie quotidienne alors ça crée
énormément et légitimement beaucoup
d'inquiétudes alors là c'est le ministre
qui parle la Food tech effectivement la
souveraineté alimentaire mais maintenant
je m'adresse aux gourmand ou aux
gourmets que vous êtes
est-ce que vous n'avez pas peur que ces
innovations bien sacrifient un peu le
goût et la saveur sur l'hôtel de de
l'économie durable j'ai un exemple parmi
les 16 innovations qui ont été
récompensées Brigitte il y a un
substitut de viande confectionné à
partir de caroube par ex est un fruit je
connaissais pas et de farine de riz
alors on nous dit que ça retrouve
l'expert la texture de la viande ça vous
fait envie ça vous avez envie de farcir
votre chou avec avec ça
ce qui est certain c'est vrai
ne poussez pas répondu
faites le moi goûter le juge de paix
c'est les papilles
et de la farine de riz et qu'on nous dit
que ça retrouve l'aspect la texture de
la viande ça fait pas très envie comme
ça ça a été pris mais la question c'est
est-ce que ça est-ce qu'on retrouve le
goût et le juge de paix c'est la papille
et c'est de savoir si elle retrouve ou
non le goût en plus de la texture etc
donc je suis pas très inquiet là-dessus
en tout cas s'agissant du du peuple
français qui est très attaché au Bien
manger qui est très attaché à
accès qu'il peut avoir des aliments de
qualité à la cuisine qui est un art
national donc je suis pas très inquiet
si des substituts ou des produits nous
sont proposés qui ne s'élève pas au
niveau d'exigence jusqu'au niveau
d'exigence qui est le nôtre alors ils
ont du mal à trouver un marché à
l'inverse si certains arrivent à
produire de nouveaux goûts de nouvelles
textures ou à reproduire des goûts
auxquels nous sommes très attachés à
partir d'éléments ou d'aliments qui sont
moins carbonés alors ils ont à mon avis
toutes leurs places dans notre assiette
aujourd'hui on est en période
d'inflation assez forte crise quand même
est-ce que ça ça ne freine pas
l'innovation
les prix de l'énergie l'incertitude qui
entoure
l'année 2023 le contexte géopolitique
tout cela c'est évidemment pas idéal
pour la croissance et donc ça touche
évidemment toutes les toutes les
entreprises que ce soit des startups ou
des grands groupes je dois dire
cependant que on constate
que la french tech que les entreprises
de l'innovation en France résistent
plutôt mieux que leurs homologues aux
États-Unis ou dans d'autres pays
d'Europe on a eu cette année un nouveau
record de levée de fond pour les
entreprises innovantes
la place de Paris donc la Bourse de
Paris c'est ici à la première place des
Bourses européennes au sens large c'est
à dire devant la Grande-Bretagne et
aujourd'hui même nous avons une 29e
entreprise qui a atteint le statut de de
licorne c'est-à-dire d'entreprise
valoriser à plus de 1 milliard d'euros
c'est United une start-up qui vise à
démocratiser le crédit à la consommation
donc bien sûr qu'on est vigilant dans
cette période bien sûr que l'incertitude
que le contexte géopolitique que les
prix de l'énergie ne sont pas très
favorables ou très porteurs pour la
croissance mais il y a aussi des de quoi
se réjouir et tout ce
vent d'innovation qui s'ouvre sur le
pays depuis 5 ans notamment depuis
l'élection la première élection
d'Emmanuel Macron je pense que ce
n'était pas qu'un vent de passage avant
conjoncturel mais qui a bien une
tendance de fond et que nous
traverserons dans cette crise mais la
demande est-ce que vous croyez que les
consommateurs ils se tournent pas plutôt
vers des valeurs refuges quand c'est la
crise ou quand il y a de l'inflation
plutôt que vers des innovations qui vont
peut-être pas aimer ou peut-être pas
vouloir consommer ça dépend vous voyez
pendant la crise de la covid si on
n'avait pas eu
doctolib cette belle innovation
française on aurait eu du mal à
réussir la campagne de vaccination
donc il arrive que les technologies
viennent à point nommer pour nous
permettre de surmonter les crises
Brigitte parlait plutôt de produits
alimentaires sont très hauts est-ce
qu'on va pas vers des valeurs refuges et
des valeurs sûres des prix un peu moins
cher peut-être que les innovations sont
aussi un petit peu plus les innovations
en train d'arriver elles ont pas encore
complètement pris leur place dans les
dans les habitudes alimentaires et ce
qu'effectivement les craintes qui
portent sur le pouvoir d'achat sur la
foot tech ou peut-être sur d'autres
habitudes de consommation des courages
la le consommateur à la prise de risque
c'est c'est vraisemblable mais ça ne
remet pas en question la valeur de ces
innovations puisque vous le savez les
les l'économie c'est un cycle et les
innovations notamment celles qui sont
les meilleures elles résistent à ces
cycles là d'ailleurs il y a des
innovations qui naissent pendant les
périodes de crise quand vous pensez à
uber quand vous pensez à Airbnb quand
vous pensez à slack si vous utilisez
slack qui est une outil de collaboration
en entreprise ce sont des entreprises
qui ont été créées en 2008 et 2009 c'est
à dire au moment de la grande crise
financière et donc peut-être qu'il y a
aujourd'hui parmi ces entreprises de la
de la Food Tech qui sont en train de
naître ou de se créer pendant cette
période de crise et des entreprises qui
vont ensuite croître et se faire
connaître en toute la France en Europe
et dans le monde parce que vous croyez
au steak de labo par exemple puisque là
il y a une vraie polémique sur l'élevage
intensif etc est-ce que vous pensez que
le steak de labo peut en un mot peut
dites moi ce que c'est que le steak
balade avec des cellules souches on
fabrique avec des petites cellules d'une
tirée d'une vache on fabrique à l'infini
des steaks des steaks qui ont
l'apparence de la viande mais qui sont
tirés de cellules
je demande à voir si ce steak tiré de
cellules peut atteindre
le goût le goût atteint le goût atteint
le Fin Gras d'une maison qui est une qui
est une appellation de la Haute-Loire et
qui me semble assez imbattable et
imitable à la fois en goût mais aussi en
prix mais bon voilà allez on va
continuer à parler des prix et de la
flambée des prix de l'énergie qui
inquiète les artisans qui n'arrivent
plus à faire face on en parle et on met
les pieds dans le plat
la semaine dernière les bouchers sont
descendus dans la rue une première
depuis la crise de la vache folle il y a
20 ans les boulangers tirent aussi la
sonnette d'alarme leur facture
d'électricité explose avec leur four
très énergivores et ils craignent de
mettre la clé sous la porte reportage
les osseux et Charlotte
comme chaque matin Ludovic artisan
boulanger se lance dans la confection de
ces 700 baguettes quotidiennes mais en
ce moment son obsession c'est le prix de
l'énergie gaz comme électricité ces
factures vont bondir dès le mois de
janvier impossible pour lui de faire
sans son matériel énergivore
là ici on a des chambres de pouce pour
stocker les baguettes la fermentation et
tout donc moi j'en ai trois donc
celle-là c'est une double porte donc ça
consomme deux fois plus puisque à chaque
fois ils ont des températures
différentes
ça c'est mon four ma plus grosse
consommation
dans ce que j'ai reçu par engie moi je
serai multiplié par 5 sur le gaz et par
5 sur l'électricité des factures
multipliées par 5 dès le mois de janvier
alors en boutique les prix des
pâtisseries et des pains spéciaux ont
déjà augmenté et les clients sont
avertis une explication leur est donnée
en vitrine
là on a fait une hausse de 10 centimes
par produit en espérant qu'on arrive à
tenir après la pâtisserie reste en
produit plaisir donc oui ils sont prêts
peut-être à payer ces 10 centimes là
manque en ce moment moins forcément quoi
baguette et traditions sont pour
l'instant épargnés mais plus pour
longtemps alors les clients sont-ils
prêts à payer plus cher la baguette
un peu plus cher si il faut c'est gentil
tout dépend on va pas faire des bons de
100 % de 50% de mes 10 centimes pourquoi
pas c'est compréhensible mais bon avoir
donné il faut qu'on arrête je sais pas
où on va aller
mais la bonne volonté des clients ne
suffit pas à rassurer
en coulisses l'inquiétude monte la
facture mensuelle va passer de 2000 à
10.000 euros soit 20% du chiffre
d'affaires du boulanger l'État a promis
des aides mais Ludovic ne s'est toujours
pas combien il touchera je suis dans le
flou je suis dans le flou parce que tu
peux pas me projeter et pour la suite
toutes les options sont sur la table
l'avenir de le dire
et les boulangers ne sont pas les seuls
dans le désarroi les bouchers sont aussi
touchés de plein fouet par la hausse des
prix de l'énergie fin novembre il
manifestait devant l'Assemblée avec un
message qu'est-ce qu'on entend qui nous
fasse un blocage comme j'ai entendu que
l'Espagne l'Italie et l'Allemagne avait
fait
un blocage sur le prix pour les
entreprises il faut qu'il nous fassent
la même chose les dernières annonces sur
de nouveaux dispositifs sont bien
accueillis mais ne suffisent pas à
convaincre des petits commerçants qui
s'inquiètent pour leur avenir
alors j'en ai marre au moment où et bien
la baguette est inscrite au patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO on voit ses artisans
boulangers qui sont menacés ce qui est
pas un paradoxe quand même français là
d'abord la reconnaissance de la baguette
au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO c'est
une immense fierté pour pour la France
pour l'artisanat et puis singulièrement
pour les les boulangers ou le métier de
boulanger qui est sans doute
l'artisan que le que les Français que
nous concitoyens rencontrent le plus
souvent dans leur quotidien
donc pour ma part j'ai été assez émue
des images qui de cette de cette de
cette cérémonie ou en tout cas de cette
décision qui a été prise à l'Unesco
pour autant là on voit nos petits
commerces qui sont menacés donc
peut-être qu'il y aura plus de baguettes
demain mais la baguette était éternelle
et les difficultés sont conjoncturelles
mais comme nous l'avons fait depuis
maintenant le mois de mars 2020 quand la
première des deux grandes crises que qui
qui s'enchaînent ou qui viennent de
s'enchaîner à commencer en apportant
très vite des réponses à toutes nos
entreprises et singulièrement au plus
petites dès l'année dernière à partir du
mois d'octobre quand les prix ont frémis
quand l'inflation a commencé à montrer
son son nez le gouvernement a mis sur la
place sur la table une batterie de
mesure d'abord pour protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des Français et les boulangers
se sont aussi des Français et c'est
ainsi que un an plus tard la France est
de tous les pays d'Europe celui où
l'inflation a été la plus contenue la
vérité la plus faible grâce aux mesures
qui ont été déployées par le
gouvernement français puis ensuite dans
un deuxième temps non
c'est posé la question des entreprises
et qui ont elle aussi été
bénéficiaires d'un certain nombre de
protections depuis quelques mois avec
une écoute très attentive de la part du
gouvernement et en particulier de Bruno
Le Maire et de mes deux collègues Roland
Lescure et Olivier agrégoire et
d'ailleurs Bruno Le Maire a annoncé ce
matin que le guichet auquel peuvent
s'adresser les TPE et les PME serait
maintenu en 2023 en plus de
l'amortisseur électricité je pense que
c'était important pour apprendre jusqu'à
35 % à peu près de la facture des
énergies de des artisans si j'ai bien
compris absolument et c'est une réponse
directe à
aux attentes des artisans et
singulièrement des boulangers mais moi
je vous dis en lien avec la boulangerie
un exemple qui m'a beaucoup frappé qui
est celui des moulins de Versailles
moulin de Versailles est une Entreprise
du Patrimoine Vivant c'est un c'est un
label qui est accordé aux entreprises
qui continuent de fonctionner sur la
base de savoir-faire français et donc de
machine qui peuvent être relativement
anciennes et donc extrêmement énergivore
c'est une usine en plein centre-ville de
Versailles qui continuent ou qui
perpétuent une tradition et un
savoir-faire et qui s'est retrouvé et
qui se retrouve aujourd'hui coincé entre
la hausse des prix du et puis la hausse
des prix de l'énergie je crois qu'il
était évidemment indispensable
ces derniers mois de pouvoir apporter
des réponses fortes et je salue la
décision qui a été prise
et annoncée ce matin par Bruno Le Maire
de maintenir ce guichet qui va apporter
un bol d'oxygène qui vont se poursuivre
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2023 ou vous
les a enfin vous les poursuivrez tant
qu'il y aura des prix élevés de
l'énergie c'est ce que je comprends mais
toujours dans dans en essayant de cibler
les aides vers ceux qui en ont le le
plus besoin en tout cas c'est dans cet
esprit là que le gouvernement travail
c'est pas le plus facile parfois il est
plus simple de d'arroser très large pour
essayer de n'oublier personne mais je
crois que dans la rue il faut être
attentif à ne pas arroser trop large et
donc à cibler les aides sur ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin et je sais que ça a
demandé beaucoup de travail dans notre
ministère dans le ministère de Bruno Le
Maire nos équipes et aux directions pour
pouvoir calibrer ces dispositifs au
mieux vous allez éviter tout
licenciement toute faillite vous pouvez
nous le garantir ou pas
vous savez il y a des cycles économiques
assez naturels ce que je peux dire en
tout cas c'est que les fondamentaux qui
ont les fondamentaux sur lesquels sont
assis les grandes réussites de la France
et 5 dernières années le chômage au plus
bas depuis 18 ans je mange des jeunes au
plus bas depuis 40 ans le record
historique de création d'entreprises le
record d'apprentissage tout cela n'était
pas le fruit de la conjoncture tout cela
est fait pour durer puisque nous avons
mis en oeuvre des réformes structurelles
qui ont permis d'obtenir ces résultats
et qui nous l'espérons vont continuer
d'en produire suite nous traversons une
période compliquée où il y aura
peut-être un peu moins de croissance un
peu moins de création d'emplois mais je
suis confiant que à l'issue de cette
période là et notamment lorsque
l'incertitude sur le contexte
géopolitique sur la disponibilité de
l'énergie se dissipera alors les
entreprises se remettront investir se
remettront à employer puisque la France
est comme vous le savez devenu le pays
le plus attractif en Europe pour les
investissements étrangers ça veut dire
qu'il c'est bon il investir innover y
employer alors le pain est un aliment de
base un symbolique sacré même qu'est-ce
que vous inspire c'est ces témoignages
qu'on a vu dans le reportage de clients
qui sont dits qui disent bah moi je suis
prêt à
payer 10 20 centimes de plus cette
solidarité des clients vis-à-vis des
boulangers
d'abord elle me elle je la trouve très
belle cette cette solidarité telle
qu'elle est exprimée elle me fait penser
à beaucoup de solidarité qu'on a vu
traverser le pays depuis deux ans au
moment de la période de covid pour
commencer ou dans toute la France des
collectifs se sont montés pour fabriquer
des masques pour apporter de l'aide aux
personnes isolées ou en difficulté
pendant la période pendant depuis le
début de la guerre en Ukraine ou des
collectivités des collectifs ce sont
levés des citoyens se sont levés pour
apporter de l'aide très concrète soit en
acheminant du matériel soit en recevant
des réfugiés et je trouve que c'est dans
ce même esprit qu'on doit affronter la
période un peu difficile que nous
traversons ou l'Europe et en quelque
sorte la région du monde qui est exposée
à la très forte hausse des prix de
l'électricité avec des conséquences à la
fois pour le pouvoir d'achat c'est vrai
pour notre
approvisionnement en électricité d'autre
part avec des des risques si nous ne
prenons pas pas les mesures mais les
Français l'ont fait donc on voit bien
depuis le depuis le début de l'automne
qui puisse y avoir quelques
interruptions d'électricité donc cet
esprit de
cet esprit de solidarité nationale je
pense que c'est la meilleure chose qui
puisse nous arriver pour traverser cette
période de crise nous avons entendu dans
le reportage il y en a qui disait il
faudrait qu'il bloque les prix ça s'est
fait en Espagne en Italie et en
Allemagne c'est une réflexion qu'il y a
eu à Bercy on a bloqué on a bloqué les
prix de l'électricité on a bloqué les
prix du gaz pour les pour les
particuliers c'est bien ce que nous
avons fait de manière conjoncturelle
ensuite de manière certains critères de
manière structurelle ce que nous voulons
faire c'est réformer le marché européen
de l'électricité pour que durablement on
puisse éviter ce type de pique
d'électricité face de pique de prix pics
de prix auquel nos entreprises le gaz
électricité et puis par ailleurs de
renforcer et de décupler notre puissance
nucléaire puisque c'est vraiment ça
notre meilleure arme à long terme pour
pour éviter d'être confronté
à des crises comme celles qu'on traverse
qui pourrait se répéter et se multiplier
dans la tant nous sommes entrés dans une
nouvelle époque de tension géopolitique
et de tension liée aussi aux
conséquences du dérèglement climatiques
allez on va passer au dessert à présent
et c'est le péché mignon
alors voici volume du temps de sucré
avec un éclair au café avant d'être
désigné ainsi il s'appelait petite
duchesse cette pâtisserie française est
fabriquée depuis 1850 à partir de pâte à
choux décidément le ministre est très
chou il est farci lui aussi de crème
pâtissière généralement au chocolat ou
au café c'est votre choix selon le
dictionnaire de l'Académie française il
porte le nom des clairs car il se
déguste rapidement et ben il porte bien
son nom parce que
non
c'est quoi votre record pour manger un
éclair monsieur le ministre
j'oserai pas le dire comme ça à
l'antenne puisque précisément je dis ah
mais
à mes enfants de prendre le temps de
savourer donc je donnerai le mauvais
exemple mais
pour moi il y a là aussi une histoire un
peu d'enfance et de une histoire un peu
familiale puisque chaque été
quand nous étions jeunes avec mes
parents et mes sœurs vous allez
régulièrement dans le même hôtel
avec un buffet de dessert
où on pouvait trouver des éclairs au
café et des éclairs au chocolat et
j'avais déjà une passion et donc mon
père prenant par la main m'emmenait au
buffet des desserts et je m'étais un peu
donner une sorte de discipline qui était
de choisir un jour l'éclair au café un
jour l'éclair au club mais j'avais une
sorte de préférence secrète pour le cœur
au café et
ce que je constate
c'est que il y a une sorte de dimension
héréditaire à cette question pour les
claires au café
alors mon fils et ma fille sont son
grand amateur 3 et 6 ans un déclare au
café aussi et mon c'est un goule qui a
fait et mon fils ne se satisfait pas de
l'éclat au café donc il choisit plutôt
une religieuse ah oui c'est-à-dire la
version du dessus voilà et vous êtes
gourmand parce que j'ai vu que quand
l'éclair est arrivé vous avez commencé à
manger vous pouvez pas résister à une
pât comme ça
yssinge la ville dans laquelle j'ai
grandi à sa brioche son par-ci c'est
lentilles vertes du volley mais aussi
une école nationale supérieure de la
pâtisserie et donc
dans le monde entier vous allez trouver
des pâtissiers
les plus prestigieux qui ont fait un
passage à yssinge l'école est
aujourd'hui gérée par
la filiale formation du groupe d'Alain
Ducasse qui a d'autres écoles de
formation notamment une à Meudon très
loin de on en a parlé dans cette
émission que j'ai visité il y a pas très
longtemps je vous invite à aller
découvrir l'école de pâtisserie 10 un
jour et donc
j'ai été très jeune
sensibiliser à au génie pâtissier
français je le dirai comme ça puis je
crois que je suis juste un grand
gourmand et donc effectivement j'essaye
de ne
j'essaye de ne pas abuser de la
pâtisserie mais c'est vrai quand elle
m'est proposé comme vous l'avez fait
j'ai du mal à y résister il est plutôt
bon et les éclairs au match à la rose
parce que maintenant les éclairs de
toutes les couleurs de tous les goûts
vous êtes plutôt classiques vous restez
sur votre valeur sur le café moi j'aime
bien explorer donc je je me suis livré à
cette exploration il y a même des
boutiques il y avait des spécial avec le
spécial éclair etc mais enfin
et puis l'éclair au chocolat juste
derrière merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis merci à chez Françoise pour ces
bons petits plats et on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de politique à table sur l